what's next rather all right well next
up you know it's so great when someone
can take a space and really make it
their own right well the independent
reports one man did just that when he
turned his boring office cubicle into a
log cabin lucas mont made his own
mountain man sanctuary out of the wood a
wood paneling look at this a stove
there's a even a moose head in there
look at that's his cubicle and he did
all this i have to tell you you know why
i love this
this
this man has combined two of my deepest
darkest fantasies into one like because
i have a big time little house on the
prairie fantasy like i always want to
live like paw ingles you know in the
woods and then yeah a yellow stone
exactly and then i've also so gross why
do i pant like a dog what's wrong with
me
i know why you pant like a dog hello so
little house on the prairie fantasy for
one and then i've always had like a
headset fantasy you know what i mean
like
you know where people get to wear them
like thank you for calling thank you so
much and you do that in a cubicle but
i've never had a job where i get a
headset is any of these fantasies sexual
or just lifestyle and fashion driven
well i don't know i need to get the
headset and i'll let you know
[Applause]
oh
thank you for calling 976 ross this is
ross speaking how may director call
i don't know how does it look you guys
like it
it's not you look like like a sports
commentator not plugged in anything so
is it cool if i just wear this every day
now is that cool whatever floats your
boat right thank you
all right and now it's time for a pic
from the little yellow book that's right
it's my list of things that i love
and i created every week
goes up on our website on fridays and
we're obsessed with celebrating black
owned businesses all month long and
today we've got the headlights beanie by
rock innovation and if you're out
walking the dog in the dark this can be
a game changer for that i also say
never not keep a headlamp in your
bedside table drawer in case of
emergencies really i'll look at you
laugh now you won't be laughing later
wow
uh well you guys this this is a bright
idea
put your put your thing on now on top of
that rossi oh yeah oh look at this but
this actually pops out and it's
rechargeable
um thank you for calling
we leave our light on for you
but i have to tell you like i am a
really big headlamp advocate it you
there are so many situations where you
need a light and you need to be
hands-free
and it's just super empowering i wear
this to read at night too it's not just
for emergencies like what are you doing
in your life that you have so many
situations where you need a headlamp
what do you what do you spend your time
doing reading
um
i'll wait
um hold on one second
can i place you on a brief hold
um
i have little like things that i store
in like darker places where i need a
headlamp while i'm riffling stuff around
i'm worried about the situation at home
i'm like a raccoon yeah i was gonna say
what are you looking for i'm looking up
to lighten up the dark spaces anyway get
one of these we love the business i love
this we advocate
[Music]